et bien je vous propose de voir ce qui
se passe dans les hypermarchés parce que
le bio ce n'est pas seulement réservé à
certaines échoppes spécialisés les
hypermarchés se sont engouffrés dans
cette brèche ils veulent dans un premier
temps rassuré leurs clients leur montrer
qu'ils peuvent leur donner des bons
produits et puis je pense également que
le profit qu'on peut réaliser avec ça ne
laisse pas complètement indifférent mais
voyons ce qui se passe dans les
hypermarchés avec le reportage de
françois vallet et dominique bonnot les
produits bio on les trouve désormais
dans tous les rayons ils ne sont plus
cantonnées en coin et diététiques le but
est bien sûr d'attirer la curiosité du
consommateur dans cette grande surface
tout a commencé par la boule bio un pain
certifiés agriculture biologique sans
produits chimiques ils représentent
aujourd'hui la deuxième bombe du reggae
après la baguette acheter nous voir et
on la trouve bonne qui vont comment les
deux que dire elle se garde bien
vous avez plein d'autres produits bio
pour pas tout le temps non pas forcément
bon ça va être ce qu'il y avait dans les
aliments mangerai plus alors bon là oui
je prends du bio mais vous savez
est ce qu'il ya vraiment
que c'est vraiment mieux fait
comme ce client beaucoup de gens se
posent des questions des grandes
surfaces le savent et cherche à les
rassurer tout s'intéresse au bio la part
du chiffre d'affaires bio est encore
petit par contre ce sont des produits
qui se développe très rapidement ou mais
a dépassé nos prévisions de ventes mais
à +40 % par rapport à ses prévisions
ça reste quand même un petit marché mais
il ya réellement une clientèle derrière
et comme ses concurrents carrefour a
fait faire une étude avant de se lancer
le magasin a mis au point toute une
stratégie de communication pour
expliquer aux consommateurs ce qu'est
l'agriculture biologique si c'est
vraiment des gens qui potentiel ou c'est
vous et moi enfin des gens qui sont pas
des militants du bio
si justes sont intéressés ils sont
concernés par leur santé par l'avenir de
la planète partie d'un à manger à leurs
enfants et qui ont envie globalement de
manger mieux voilà plus sain en
soutenant un peu de ce qui se passe en
amont des produits comment ils sont
cultivés avec quels effets sur la
planète et de l'effet des produits dans
leur corps
démocratiser les produits bio baisser
les prix pour les rendre plus
accessibles
une perspective qui pourrait affoler les
petits détaillants
depuis des années ils se battent pour
une agriculture sans chimie
les grandes enseignes se sont
positionnés sur le bio pas la légère
indisposition de façon durable et c'est
d'autant mieux parce que ça fera des
surfaces
en bio reconverti plus nombreuses et
donc je dirais ça va dans le bon sens au
niveau de la du respect des sols durs à
ce que l'environnement au niveau de
l'agriculture
malheureusement en france sur 700 mille
agriculteurs 4000 seulement au travail
tant bio les grandes surfaces vont
devoir s'approvisionner à l'étranger
pour satisfaire la demande